can check this out get your calculator
out now make sure that it is in radians
remember that's what we said we started
with pop you're calculating radians you
get mine as well straight into there we
go so if you pop something to your
calculator choose a small angle right
where I'm radians but if we want to make
this really small try I don't know sine
of 0.01 something like that that's a
small angle isn't it like in radians
that's pretty small if you like put in
1000 1 what are you getting out can
someone actually read off their
calculators for me if you put in who put
inside 0.01 anyway yeah what did you get
okay let me actually state that one more
time zero point zero zero it just keeps
on coming
right it does it does actually it's
likely to change at some point right but
the point is see that thing right is it
not very very close to 0.01 the input
right you can try this out you can see
that's sort of a point at which they
start to diverge a little bit which
shouldn't surprise you because if you
think about what y equals x looks like
here and what y equals x looks like here
eventually your sign do you see it's
just a little bit underneath who tried
out 10 didn't even Pretender to that
calculator yet followed what did you get
when you put 10 of whatever 0 0 and then
there's like zero okay sure right now
have a look right do you see sign it's
just a little bit below what you put it
and 10 is just a little bit above what
you put in which is kind of exactly what
you ought to expect from the graph does
this make sense ok now this is the small
angle approximation but the way we
actually stayed it is slightly different
we bring back this limit language that
we had before okay and we're actually
going to state two different limits one
of these from the left hand side and the
other one from the right hand side okay
so here if you want to if you want to
put something in a big box this is what
we're going to do we're gonna say the
limit as theta approaches 0 because
that's sort of overarching this whole
thing we've taken the limit at
about this point here and everything
else that follows is within that limit
of sine theta is approximately equal to
the limit as theta approaches zero of
theta it's up that's what we've just
established you even tested it out
empirically right but what it happens is
most interesting where I'm actually
heading from here toward calculus is
more about the ratio between these two
limits so I'm gonna divide one side by
the other and I get this if I divide
this both sides by theta I'm gonna get
sine theta on theta what happens whew
there's a computer here what happens to
this right hand side I'm gonna divide
through by theta
you just get theta over theta which is
one and one is independent of theta
do you see that one is independent of
theta so you just get one that's the
actual limit that ends up being useful
to us okay I could rehearse this all
over again but you can see it doesn't
take that much imagination to realize
you're going to get the same thing with
Tim aren't you so I'm going to say
similarly the limit as theta approaches
zero of tan theta on theta also equal to
one and the last thing to note we're not
even going to write this down because
it's so trivial but hopefully you can
see it one is a useful number when it
comes to reciprocals or ratios like this
because one is its own reciprocal right
one is one over one so because I've got
sine theta over theta I could just as
easily say the reciprocal of that right
so I could just as easily say theater on
sine theta or I could just as easy to
say theater on hand theta does that make
sense so this is the actual result and
put a big box around it and I'm going to
show you how to use it in a pure context
and in apply it so if you okay so sure
you read it together
and pieces together it says a car
travels one kilometer up a road which is
inclined at five degrees to the
horizontal okay so it pause right there
we've got a length and we've got an
angle that we can place onto this
diagram where am I going to put that
angle it's just that little acute angle
isn't it it's always going to be you can
actually know in advance pretty much for
all of these questions because they're
all small-angle approximations you're
always going to be drawing sort of a
long flat right angle triangle okay so
there's my five degrees where's that one
kilometer going to go
it says driving one kilometer up this
thing where we
you place it yeah I'm gonna play some of
the hypotenuse
I will admit there is a slight ambiguity
in the question when they say you drive
up right because you like up which which
up do you mean but then the question
itself sort of clears that ambiguity in
the question because it says then this
is the thing I want to know right it
says one of the words through what
vertical distance has the car client
which is clearly this right so I'm going
to call this guy H I'm also going to
stop writing one kilometer and I'm gonna
write 1,000 meters can anyone suggest to
me what clue in the question tells me
that might be more useful have a look
yeah when I'm gonna provide this art ah
it's gonna be in meters so I might as
well get in that form from the get-go
right so there's one last thing I need
to do remember and I just left it on the
board when we started this off we drew a
circle so what form of angle where we're
using we're using radians so the last
thing I need to do is say hey that five
degrees not going to be useful form to
me at the moment convert that so can
anyone tell me right away what that's
going to be you can't reach your
calculator you probably don't need to
either do you come on where x1 we can do
this
what do you multiply by when you're
converting from degrees to radians you
multiply by is the plan the top of the
bottom it's on the top right so it's
going to be that times pi on 180 right
can anyone tell me what 180 divided by
five is can you do this all the time
it's gonna be 36 right so this is PI on
36 come on especially in complex numbers
you've been doing this enough you really
need to anyway okay come on what are you
going to do a few fifth roots of unity
anyway
okay now you write your prime 36 there
I've got my length and I'm pretty much
ready to go so this is what I'm trying
to find so which trig ratio I've only
got to really to choose from am I going
to use which connects these it's just
like being back in you're nine isn't it
okay so I'm gonna say sign I'm gonna say
sign off there's my angle right there
plan 36 and that is my small angle
because pound 36 is like 0.1 ish because
pi is 3.14 right that's going to be
equal to opposite over hypotenuse my H
on a thousand right H is going to be
exactly equal to a thousand
sine pi on 36 and at this point here I'm
going to say but I know that when you
take the limit right sine theta and
theta are basically the same thing right
so I can say for small Thea H is going
to be what exactly we saw how we were
slightly off but close enough
approximately equal to one thousand is
set of sine theta I'm just going to
substitute via just pi on 36 I should
write multiplication there so doesn't
look like a mixed numeral okay I have no
idea what a thousand lots of plastics is
and someone already reached with a
calculator can they give me to the
nearest actually give me some decimal
places I know it's in the 80s because I
already solve this but I remember yeah
we got it eighty seven point two six six
so we're rounding this off to the
nearest meter so that gives me okay so
that's that's not that complicated you
can see it's applied this this idea
which is very theoretical I've applied
it to a simple situation